à la demande générale bienvenue dans ce
nouvel épisode all trade on va dire les
histoires qui rendent hommage aux
histoires à la Bellemare voilà mais ça
suit la tendance des trades et c'est pas
vraiment de l'horreur moi les deux
premiers épisodes apparemment vous ont
beaucoup plus ça m'a fait bien plaisir
surtout qu'on les a publié au pire
moment de l'année en juillet en août
donc ben voilà un troisième épisode pour
enfin septembre ça me paraissait pas mal
aujourd'hui je vais vous raconter
l'histoire d'André Maillefer c'est
quelqu'un qui a monté une arnaque et en
1900 environ en France une arnaque qui
fonctionne encore aujourd'hui en 2022
c'est incroyable
André Maillefer est né en 1884 à Paris
dans le 11e arrondissement il s'installe
ensuite à Orléans dans le futur en tant
que peintre aquarelliste et il est fan
de meubles anciens problèmes ça coûte
cher il a pas les moyens de se les
acheter du coup qu'est-ce qui fait en
1904 à Orléans il ouvre une fabrique de
meubles anciens alors attention il y a
pas d'arnaque c'est clairement des
copies c'est annoncé comme tel selon les
versions parce qu'on sait pas trop si
quand même il en a pas vendu un petit
peu comme ça mais a priori rien illégal
là dedans et là où il est très fort avec
les artisans qui qu'il engagent c'est
qu'il arrive à monter une technique très
au point pour donner l'aspect vieilli
d'un meuble il vieillit les meuble par
des techniques qu'on appelle la brûlure
l'éclatement bref il maîtrise l'aspect
de l'ancien ça cartonne puis va venir un
gros souci sur toute la France et même
l'Europe et le monde
et lui va trouver une bonne astuce pour
s'en sortir mais quelque chose
d'improbable qui s'est jamais vu qu'à
jamais été reproduit depuis par
quelqu'un d'autre et pourtant je vous
l'ai dit qu'il fonctionne encore
aujourd'hui mais avant de rentrer dans
ce détail là laissez-moi vous parler
d'une autre vérité qui l'aille presque
nickel c'est celle du partenariat du
jour bonjour bienvenue dans ce deuxième
épisode des dossiers du Nord des vérités
presque nickel oui des dossiers du Nord
VPN sponsorisé par nordvpn aujourd'hui
nous allons découvrir la véritable
histoire de Léonard de Vinci car ici
inventé une technologie incroyable
incarnée incarner nordvpn le VPN le plus
rapide du marché le plus simple
d'utilisation grâce à sa connexion
automatique saviez-vous que lors de ces
expéditions à Venise et Florence Léonard
changer son IP pour se connecter sur les
sites de réservation de tels en faisant
ça il est économisé pas mal d'argent et
comme il le disait si bien le néant en a
point de centre et ses limites sans le
néant ce qui n'a aucun rapport avec
notre sujet ok ah Léonard Léonard
télétravailler beaucoup ça on le dit pas
par exemple en vouloir aller en France
en 1516 il emporte son carnet Nord VPN
pour se connecter en toute sécurité dans
le wifi public des auberges et des gares
françaises c'était pas construites mais
il savait que ça allait arriver bête
Léonard une fois en France est-ce qu'il
y a vraiment bluffé la cour du roi c'est
de pouvoir découvrir des programmes
étrangers en streaming grâce au carnet
nordvpn et surtout c'était bluffé que
Leonard connaisse si bien plus belle la
vie parce que lui il pouvait le voir
depuis l'Italie grâce à son carnet
nordvpn il était malade Léonard alors si
vous cherchez un VPN faites comme c'est
un menteur qui selon la légende aurait
cliqué sur le lien dans la description
pour bénéficier de l'offre actuelle il
paraît même que s'il n'était pas
satisfait en 30 jours il était remboursé
merci nordvpn et à bientôt pour une
nouvelle vérité presque nickel
je vous disais donc les affaires
cartonne et en 1913 il déménage toujours
à Orléans il prend un plus grand
bâtiment il prend plus d'artisans
toujours dans le même but produire des
meubles
identiques on va dire en meubles Louis
XV Louis XVI etc là où ça commence à
devenir rigolo c'est que des fois c'est
reproductions à lui se vendent plus cher
que les meubles originaux parce que
forcément ils sont en meilleure étape
alors selon les sources il paraîtrait
que mais j'ai pas de preuve de ça c'est
des racontars qu'il y a des antiquaires
qui achetaient donc les reproduction
légale que faisait maille faire et il
est revendait comme si c'était des
originaux a priori mail ferme ne le
savait même pas qu'il y avait ce
business là toujours selon les versions
mais c'était sympa de le noter on est à
l'apogée de son histoire de son âge d'or
on va dire on est au moment où mail
faire emploi 250 artisans dans sa
fabrique et vraiment c'est une industrie
qui roule ça fabrique du meuble savant
du meuble aujourd'hui avec tout ce qu'on
a retrouvé on sait qu'il est pas très
bon en pour vendre les meubles c'est
assez rustique c'est assez grossier au
final donc c'est c'est destiné un petit
peu aux amateurs mais pas vraiment au
collectionneurs et je pense qu'à ce
moment là il le sait parce que je pense
qu'il a déjà le germe un peu de
l'escroquerie surtout tout ça depuis le
début je vous dis à chaque fois selon
les versions a priori tout ça est légal
et tout mais j'ai quand même retrouvé
des indices qui laissent à penser que
cet homme c'était un peu un peu un petit
barnum c'est à dire que ça le dérangeait
pas de flirter un petit peu avec la
vérité et d'enjoliver on va dire un
petit peu les choses comme comme du
spectacle j'ai un exemple pour ça mais
le faire avait embauché un ébéniste qui
s'appelait du bois et à l'époque il y
avait un très célèbre et pénis qui
s'appelait Jacques Dubois donc son
travail était connu apprécié et
recherché malfert demandait à son propre
ébéniste qui avait pour le patronyme
identique du bois d'estampillé tous les
sièges Louis XV qui fabriquait dans la
fabrique dans l'usine donc il y avait
marqué du bois dessus fabrication du
bois
mais pas le bon du bois et ça me ferait
il le sait c'est pas hasard de faire ça
à ce moment là c'est à dire que parfois
quand on trouvait une pièce et qu'on s'y
connaissait pas si on se dit en plus
c'est un Dubois c'est c'est vraiment
waouh c'est incroyable quand même pas
tant que ça du coup donc vous voyez il y
avait déjà ce genre d'indice des sortes
de germe un petit peu de l'escroquerie
qui va suivre maintenant en 1931 on a
une grosse crise en France et en Europe
alors c'est des conséquences de la crise
de 29 aux États-Unis qui met deux ans en
fait à impacter l'Europe c'est une
énorme crise économique la France va
très mal et il y a beaucoup de
licenciements on va les faire en fait
partie il doit licencier ses salariés
les affaires vont très mal en France y
compris pour lui mais il a pas envie de
faire ça alors il a pas envie peut-être
parce que il tient en fait à ses
employés il tient un système qui l'a
monté peut-être que c'est de l'ego le
fait et qui doit trouver une solution et
il en trouve une il va continuer à
proposer des copies
toujours annoncé comme étant des copies
mais celle d'une école d'ébénisterie qui
a disparu qui s'appelle l'école de la
Loire et ce sera forcément des copies
puisque les originaux de ces meubles de
l'école de la Loire n'existent plus il
en existe plus un seul dans le monde et
ça on en est sûr on en est sûr et
certain vous savez pourquoi parce que
l'école de la Loire n'a jamais existé
c'est une invention de Maillefer il a
littéralement créé la légende de l'école
de la Loire pour faire des copies de
cette légende puisque il n'y a pas
d'origino qui existe on peut déjà sentir
à quel point cette histoire est folle
mais le faire commence par se procurer
du papier ancien daté de l'époque de la
Renaissance pour ça il va au Musée
d'Orléans parce que il a été dit que
dans les combles du musée sur un
rangement on a retrouvé comme ça du
vieux papier et on le vend donc lui il
en achète tout un stock et il se met à
dessiner dessus parce qu'il est peintre
aqualiste il dessine une centaine de
meubles comme ça à l'aquarelle alors
c'est des meubles qui ressemblent un
petit peu au style Louis XV mais en
rustique en plus facile à fabriquer
c'est étonnant il fait quelque chose de
très sobre avec quelques motifs
décoratifs toujours les mêmes c'est soit
des châteaux soit des bateaux beaucoup
de bateaux et lui à l'époque il a pas
encore les publicités de formation en
ligne sur Facebook des infopreneurs et
des
formateurs de devient riche en trois
jours pourtant il sait qu'il faut un bon
storytelling pour vendre et il va en
créer il commence par inventer un
créateur parce que s'il y a des meubles
il faut qu'il y a un bon créateur
derrière il va s'appeler Jean-François
Hardy ce serait un grand maître ebeniste
dit 18e siècle et d'ailleurs il existe
tellement qu'on a une gravure de lui
cette représentation m'aille faire va
trouver ça opus en fait c'est un abbé un
curé qui est représenté avec un bateau
qui coule derrière lui il va juste
rajouter à l'aquarelle une perruque au
gars et ça va devenir Jean-François
Hardy donc pour que vous compreniez bien
la suite Maillefer
à créer lui-même l'école de la Loire et
la centaine de meubles qui seraient
issus de l'école de la Loire il va en
reproduire des copies qui va vendre en
gros il va se copier lui-même c'est du
gène on est toujours en 1931 et la
Maillefer va faire éditer une plaquette
très luxueuse très chère à fabriquer
pour donner ça aux amateurs aux
collectionneurs et aux professionnels
qui va présenter cette découverte des
anciens meubles issus de l'école de la
Loire il envoie tout ça aux experts donc
de si on va retrouver évidemment des
dessins des meubles on va retrouver
l'histoire de Hardy avec la
représentation de Hardy et surtout on va
retrouver le texte qui est sur la
plaquette que Maillefer écrit lui-même
que je vais vous lire enfin je vais vous
lire un extrait il me semble nécessaire
d'expliquer le pourquoi de l'engouement
subi du public pour le style de l'école
de la Loire encore presque ignoré il y a
quelques mois
là déjà c'est pas vrai pas d'engouement
puisque quelques jours avant personne
savait ce que c'était peut-être
serait-il temps de dire qui est ce
Jean-François Hardy dont beaucoup
entendent parler pour la première fois
en 1715 Jean-François Hardy l'élève
préférée du maître ébéniste Germain
Landrin fournisseur de la corde de
France dans les ateliers duquel il avait
conquis successivement l'apprentissage
le compagnonage et la maîtrise au bout
de 10 ans entrepris un voyage en
Hollande pour se perfectionner dans son
état Jean-François Hardy s'arrêta en
route à Lille ou son passage est signalé
par divers travaux d'art exécutés au
château de fournants Weppes
là déjà on est sur du full bullshit mais
pas grave parce qu'il y a pas internet
ou Google pour faire des vérifications
de là il gagna Bruxelles pour y
travailler quelques temps sous la
direction de mettre Jean horte puis il
arrive en Hollande où il se fixa à
Rotterdam dans une maison près du port
il se marie en 1719 avec la fille d'un
riche bourmetre Cornélia vanderbret dont
il eut trois enfants Petrus et Bernard
qui continuent à son œuvre en France et
Marguerite qui épousa un ebeniste de
Nantes voyez je vous parlais de
storytelling il va loin il va en
profondeur là-dedans son fils aîné
Pétrus s'établit à Orléans pour y
poursuivre l'oeuvre de son père en
association avec gaillard rue du bœuf
sans notre office s'installa à Angers où
il s'illustre dans les meubles et
boiseries de l'évêché on signale
également à agent Saumur et à Sonis des
ateliers plus modestes ou d'anciens
élèves du maître continua la tradition
de Jean-François Hardy en reproduisant
plus ou moins habilement ces modèles
il est curieux de constater que tous ces
noms aucun ne soit cités par les auteurs
des ouvrages sur les ébénistes du XVIIIe
siècle l'almanach général des marchands
par les cependants de lui comme d'un
maître vers la fin du 18e et les
tablettes de la renommée de 1770 font
également mention de ses ouvrages
il est génial il est génial je vous en
dirai pas plus sur la plaquette je
trouve que c'est tout ça qui est
intéressant c'est à dire qu'il répond
même aux critiques potentielles il dit
si ça se trouve vous en entendez parler
pour la première fois c'est très
étonnant qu'on n'entend pas parler dans
les ouvrages du 18e néanmoins il avait
été cité et on l'appelait le grand
maître de ceci de cela et puis avec le
détail de parler de l'engouement du
public quand on parle que de lui en ce
moment ce qui est vraiment faux à
l'apparition de la plaquettes mais qui
deviendra vraie après l'apparition de la
plaquette il crée comme ça un espèce de
de biais d'autorité quoi bah si tout le
monde en parle c'est qu'il faut s'y
intéresser donc il fait tout le travail
psychologique en une seule plaquette et
en plus réduction pourquoi d'après vous
derrière Hardy sur la représentation il
y a un bateau qui coule bah juste parce
que c'était comme ça quand il y avait
acheté c'est tout c'est il a pas eu le
choix à ce moment-là il a acheté ça 20
pièces il s'est débrouillé avec alors il
invente une petite fin d'histoire comme
quoi quand Hardy serait revenu de
Hollande le bateau aurait été frappé par
la foudre et que Hardy et sa famille
survécu miraculeusement en s'accrochant
une bille de citronnier qu'il aurait
permis de flotter la plaquette néanmoins
rajoute un détail que je trouve très
important dans le storytelling et dans
la psychologie de l'ensemble pour dire
c'est pas une arnaque comme ça qui a été
montée en deux secondes on est vraiment
sur un génie derrière la plaquette
explique que quand Hardy rentre en
France depuis la Hollande il retrouve le
pays ruiné en pleine difficulté
financière ça pour vous remettre dans le
contexte ce sera à cause de la
banqueroute de l'eau si vous connaissez
pas ça c'est passionnant je vous invite
à lire tout ce qui est autour du système
de l'eau c'est entre 1716 et 1720 je
vous mettrai un lien dans la description
à ce sujet si vous voulez creuser un
petit peu c'est incontournable pour
comprendre ce qui est vraiment la bourse
et pourquoi ça finit toujours mal en
fait en réalité la spéculation en gros
en 1716 il voulait mettre en avant le
papier monnaie en faisant spéculer sur
l'or et sur les richesses coloniales de
l'époque en 1720 quasiment tous les
actionnaires veulent récupérer leur
heure physique sauf qu'il y a trois fois
plus de papier monnaie qui a été édité
que et de richesse coloniale réellement
disponible et réellement en stock ce qui
va créer la banqueroute à ce moment là
si tout ça ça vous rappelle une vidéo
que j'ai sorti récemment sur l'argent et
l'argent dette ben on voit que c'est pas
d'aujourd'hui bref revenons-en à Hardy
donc Hardy retrouve comme ça le pays
ruiné le peuple en grande difficulté et
il se dit moi je suis un gars sympa je
vais inventer des meubles que tout le
monde pourra se payer parce qu'ils
seront pas trop chers sont pas trop
difficiles à fabriquer mais néanmoins
ils auront quand même un style un petit
truc et je vais aider mon pays comme ça
et donc coup de bol pour maille faire
c'est que en 1931 le pays se trouve dans
le même état avec la crise de 29 dis
donc c'est quand même c'est un bon
hasard ça c'est fou quand même donc ça
tombe si bien dans un premier temps tout
le monde demande à maille faire comment
il rentrait en possession de ses
documents et pourquoi on en a
connaissance que maintenant donc il
explique que quand la plupart de ces
employés ont dû partir à la guerre de 14
il organisait un gros pot une grosse
réception parce que tu comprends c'est
une famille
à souder les uns les autres et que au
moment de tranquilles l'un de ses
employés qui s'appelle Simon Hardy
aurait dit voilà boss je j'ai une mal
que je tiens de mon aïeul j'aimerais
bien que vous la conserviez en mon
absence et si jamais je reviens pas je
vous autorisais à l'ouvrir évidemment et
mal faire explique qu'il avait rangé sa
mal dans son grenier qui n'en avait
oublié l'existence et il y a quelques
temps il a rangé son grenier il a
retrouvé cette malle et six mois Hardy
malheureusement son ancien employé ne
serait pas revenu de la guerre donc il a
ouvert une vieille mal avec la peau de
truie je crois pas terrible dit comme ça
il aurait trouvé ces documents avec
stupéfaction il se serait dit il faut
que que j'offre ça au monde et puis ça
aurait pris une ampleur d'où l'édition
on a de la plaquette actuelle et cette
campagne va elle aussi cartonner les
magazines vont en parler Maillefer va
même faire une conférence radiophonique
alors à audit bah ça va il est passé à
la radio sur skyrock c'est bon c'est pas
si simple à l'époque c'était extrêmement
rare en fait d'avoir une conférence
radio il fait ça au poste national avec
la magnifique bénédiction du ministère
des Beaux-Arts rien que ça il a même
fait la couverture d'un magazine d'art
et un spécial Noël enfin on voit bien
que tout le pays et tout ce qui s'y
connaissent dans l'immeuble et dans
l'art s'empare dessus et sans part
tellement de ce sujet
que ça devient très drôle j'ai
l'impression de voir Twitter avant
Twitter il sort les meubles évidemment
je fais un peu l'impasse dessus mais il
fabrique bien les reproductions des
meubles de l'école de la Loire ça se
vend comme des petits pains quoi je veux
dire il y a pas de il y a pas de souci
là-dessus c'est un carton il prend
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup
[Musique]
d'argent et pourquoi je vous dis ça
devient Twitter avant l'heure parce
qu'on commence à lire des critiques sur
les meubles de Maillefer sur les
reproductions de Maillefer de l'école de
la Loire par exemple il y a un expert
qui écrit dans un magazine que Maillefer
ne copie pas assez bien les meubles du
maître Hardy selon lui je fais la
citation du magazine vous avez tué
l'oeuvre de François Hardy
lui-même ça va encore plus loin il y a
un journaliste du Figaro qui retrouve à
Tours une maison ou habitée François
Hardy ces rues de la sellerie et on doit
y apposer une plaque commémorative que
le justement le ministère des beaux-arts
a commandé pour mettre comme ça sur la
maison alors il y a pas une plaque il y
a pas une plaque non pas parce que mal
faire c'est fait des masquer mais parce
que il a joué un autre coup encore plus
incroyable ça on reviendra dessus dans
quelques secondes juste pour terminer
dans cette folle épopée le musée de bois
par exemple a aménagé une salle pour
accueillir les meubles du style François
Hardy et pouvoir en faire une exposition
c'est une dingré c'est une agré aussi
parce que bien sûr que les meubles se
vendent beaucoup plus cher que les
originaux puisqu'il n'y a pas
d'originaux mais on sait qu'il y avait
des originaux ça se vendrait moins cher
que ce qu'elle a parce qu'il gère
l'offre et la demande en plus donc ça
fait monter le prix alors pourquoi il y
a pas eu la plaque au mémoratif parce
qu'en 1935 my fer joue un coup énorme
il s'est clairement gavé financièrement
c'est salarié aussi il la redistribué
beaucoup d'argent il va sortir un livre
ce livre s'appelle au pays des
antiquaires on peut encore le trouver
aujourd'hui en librairie et sur les
sites en ligne habituels c'est très
marrant à lire dans ce livre il avoue
tout et il les gratigne très très très
fort les antiquaires il règle ses
comptes donc dans le bouquin il explique
tout ce que je viens de vous raconter
dire que c'est très facile de sourcer
cette histoire puisque Maël faire à tout
expliqué et alors le plus drôle dans ce
coup là c'est que ce livre là aussi va
être un succès parce que je suis sûr que
même vous là vous avez un peu envie de
lire l'histoire de son point de vue vous
avez peut-être envie de lire comment il
attaque les antiquaires à l'époque enfin
il est franchement il y va pas avec des
gants quoi c'est très violent et donc il
l'ironie sur toute cette histoire sur la
spéculation il se pose un peu en
chevalier blanc ce qui est assez marrant
parce que si on prend vraiment au pied
de la lettre son livre on se dit
d'accord le gars a créé l'école de la
Loire
faut vraiment dénoncer le système des
antiquaires et du marché de l'art mais
dans le fond vous serez sûrement
d'accord avec moi dans l'analyse quand
on voit par exemple à l'époque où il
avait embauché du bois l'artisan parce
qu'il avait le même prénom qu'un
ébéniste connu qui s'appelait du bois
pour apposer les sauts du bois et jouer
sur l'ambiguïté on voit bien que c'est
pas quelqu'un qui qui voulait qui
voulait changer le système moi en tout
cas si vous voulez le changer il savait
quand même profiter du système et ça lui
posait pas tellement de problèmes donc
certes c'est un coup de maître ce qu'il
a fait c'est magnifique le fait que
lui-même quatre ans plus tard c'est pas
très long 4 ans il s'auto dénonce en
expliquant toute sa magouille etc ça
n'enlève pas quand même complètement
qu'il a monté ce système pour s'enrichir
lui-même dans un premier temps mais
l'ambiguïté elle est forte quand même
parce qu'on se dit est-ce qu'on peut lui
en vouloir dans le sens où est-ce qu'il
a pas fourni les meubles qu'on lui a
demandé si d'ailleurs même aujourd'hui
on peut se dire c'est des originaux
c'est même pas des copies puisque c'est
bien lui qui les avait décidé c'est
juste une storytell derrière en 1935
évidemment quand il fait pas le livre il
arrête de travailler l'atelier est
repris par la famille Amos qui va
travailler dessus de 1935 à 1990 et sur
cette page là cette famille là continue
à produire des meubles anciens
aujourd'hui le terme Maillefer est
encore utilisé pour désigner des meubles
anciens les meubles qu'il a fait les
fameux meubles de l'école de la Loire se
vendent encore à bon prix sont très
recherchés ils ont un style particulier
ils ont une histoire particulière donc
il a il a réussi à créer cette légende
la preuve je vous en parle aujourd'hui
il est plus prisé et les plus recherché
c'est même pas les meubles de l'école de
la Loire justement c'est les fameux
siège Louis XV avec le saut en dessous
de du bois la vraie fausse marque était
faite au feu évidemment cette histoire
c'est du passé mais c'est quand même
aussi pas mal du présent si on regarde
sur ces dernières années pour les
affaires en tout cas qui ont été
révélées en 2016 par exemple il y a un
expert qui s'appelle Bill Palo qui est
travaillé pour la galerie Aaron qui
s'est fait démasquer qui a avoué avoir
fait des contrefaçons en décembre de la
même année 2016 jean-lucu qui est un
antiquaire s'est fait poursuivre pour un
nombre incalculable de meubles qui
étaient en fait des copies et qui
vendaient comme des originaux donc c'est
un marché en fait compliqué on voit que
tout le monde et c'est toujours de tirer
son épingle du jeu que régulièrement des
experts ou des antiquaires reconnus se
font épingler je me dis quand même que
dans le fond mais il a que créé un
storytelling il a juste créé une
histoire fausse mais techniquement il a
rien créé de faux en tant que tel
puisque les originaux sont soit disant
ses copies merci beaucoup à nordvpn
d'avoir sponsorisé cette vidéo si vous
voulez bénéficiez de leur offre le lien
est dans la description et puis vous je
compte sur vous pour vérifier que vous
êtes toujours abonné à cette chaîne
Youtube c'est mais en fait le activer la
cloche si vous voulez pas rater les
prochaines vidéos prenez soin de vous à
très bientôt Ciao